uh british troops um arriving in
afghanistan what is their role is it a
rescue mission
no it it
we are withdrawing we we made that some
months ago clear and the timetable we're
working to is obviously the american
announced timetable of september the
11th
there was always going to be a phase
where you effectively put in
logisticians air movers
command and control personnel and
a force to protect that force
and that is the appropriate moment is to
do that now so that is approximately 600
extra people will be going in the first
elements will be going in by the end of
the week
and their job is to make sure that we
can continue to process the afghan
interpreters and the wider community
that we have an obligation to
uh help draw down
some of those people from the embassy
that are going to come out as we reduce
that footprint and then lastly a group
of what we call entitled personnel those
are people who are have british passport
holders there is a theoretical number uh
you know those are people such as
security guards who might be working for
aid agencies or indeed just british
passport holders that we have an
obligation to bring out that requires
central brits are coming home
yes that's exactly right that could be
up to up to 3 000 people okay um
kandahar and lashkar is it your
understanding that both have fallen
yes they pretty much now in the hands of
the taliban
as as we speak kandahar not so much but
obviously
as well yes
um home to camp bastian of course uh
where so many british troops were based
at the time how big a mistake was it
for the brits to withdraw from
afghanistan in the manner in which we
did
well
first of all we haven't withdrawn at the
moment but i know what you're trying to
say look
i was public about it that at the time
of the trump deal with obviously the
taliban
i felt that that was a mistake to have
done it that way that
you know we'll all as an international
community probably pay the consequences
of that
but you know when the united states as
the framework nation took that decision
the way we were all configured where we
had gone in uh meant that we had to
leave as well and you know that that is
a strategic decision that has been made
though it is the case you know for 20
years we effectively bought peace on our
streets because al qaeda was unable to
launch plots from afghanistan in the way
it had and we had obviously invested in
in education and support for the afghan
government but you know i i have been
pretty blunt about it publicly and
that's quite a rare thing when it comes
to united states decision but
strategically it causes a lot of
problems and i think as an international
community it's very difficult for what
we're seeing today indeed so what
message does it send what message do our
actions does britain send to our allies
in asia in africa and in the middle east
tom tugan hearts you'll know chair of
the foreign affairs committee for the
benefit of our viewers says it shows the
world that we are not to be trusted as a
nation
well i think it's about trust i think
what it is about is that these sorts of
problems around the world
have to be managed you know you can't
just fly in fix something and then
expect it all to be fine and they have
to be managed and management for
countries like afghanistan is not one
year or five years or even 20 years it's
a long long term commitment and i think
that is that is one of the lessons i
mean the other lesson that the taliban
learned was that if you use your country
to attack another country
just because uh you know you you have
other issues going on it won't stop you
yourself being necessarily removed or
indeed people will take a response to
you and britain will always retain that
capability if if the taliban decide to
go back to what they used to do
and host al-qaeda then of course the
international community have a range of
steps that they can take but you know i
i think this is not just about britain i
think this is this is the key you know
we are a military we have a military
power we saw what happened in 2001
and people forget in 2001 there were two
military operations there was the
operation that went in to take out
al-qaeda
and remove parts of the taliban from
power because of 9 11. and that was done
pretty swiftly and pretty quickly and
then of course there was the nato
mission and that the follow-on mission
which was about stabilization and
international development at the first
authorized operations was a success and
ultimately ended in the death of osama
bin laden um but i think i think you
know and we'll retain that but i think
the lesson here is also it's not just
about britain it's really easy for for
people to make the narrative of britain
has let down afghanistan if you're going
to go to afghanistan it was very very
clear that you had to go as an
international community and the reason
you have to do that is it's not just
about military power
it's about political power it's about
soft power
you know i i've seen a number of people
saying oh britain can't do it we could
send 10 000 troops tomorrow morning and
we could we could deploy them for a
couple of years probably in afghanistan
but if you're on your own if you're on
your own you you won't get the political
leverage of the neighboring countries
that you need you won't be able to
effectively defend your position by
saying to the taliban or whoever it else
is this is the international community
concerned
and there are lots of things to be done
to put it right if you are purely a
country on your own the soviet union for
example you then face a different
consequence okay so while that diplomacy
i'm sure will be reignited with the
united states given what we're seeing
hour by unfolding in afghanistan
meantime for now we have left behind a
humanitarian crisis uh general nick
carter chief of the defence staff has
said women are being brutalized forced
marriages to taliban fighters
executions in the streets how can we
today tomorrow when those troops get
there start to try to prevent that
crisis becoming a catastrophe
well i think that's why i as i said
earlier i think that deal that was done
in doha was a rotten deal i'm on the
record of saying because what it
effectively told it told a taliban that
wasn't winning that they were winning
and it undermined the government of
afghanistan and and now we're in this
position where the taliban have clearly
the momentum
across the country and
instead of the political process working
which of course if you remember
was what the doha agreement was supposed
to do and general nick carter was very
clear and correct in pointing out that
what the political part of taliban was
saying what's going on in the ground are
not matching uh and so we are in a
difficult position you know we we've you
know the united states are leaving that
was announced yesterday we are leaving
alongside them
and that leaves a
as you say a very very big problem on
the ground uh developing with the
taliban
obviously with the momentum and it's not
what we probably would have liked not
what we wanted i did try i did try after
the announcement to see if we could
bring together the international
community
and i'm afraid most international
community weren't particularly
interested so defense secretary are you
saying what's happening at the moment
falls to the americans
no it doesn't in the end
you know
the the afghans we have put billions of
pounds in 20 years we have sacrificed
lives
lots of money lots of investment in
education three million girls educated
at school
in the end uh you know after 20 years it
is it is a perfectly legitimate question
to ask
when can afghan govern themselves it's
quite important
that you're not now not at the moment is
the answer
and the situation is as such that a
humanitarian crisis if nothing else
provides a breeding ground for uh
terrorist entities to re-establish we
remember of course that afghanistan was
the country that brought us 911
so for people watching this morning who
think this is something happening in a
country a long long way away we saw what
what can happen when these people become
disenfranchised and they send their
terrorists to our streets to kill
british people what's our plan b to try
to make sure that doesn't happen
well uh from a purely uh military point
of view we have capabilities that we can
bring to bear
from outside into a country if we have
uh the right to do so and and we do have
a right if britain is under an imminent
threat or people are plotting uh in
another country and that country won't
take action under international law we
have the ability to do something about
that we do that uh often or all over the
world we do it in certain parts of the
world and other failed state see people
will cover uh issues around i i make a
periodic announcements about
strikes we make on isis in places like
uh syria and iraq that's at the same
time afghanistan at the moment you're
not worried that that could be a
scenario as a result of what's happening
there at the moment
i'm absolutely worried that failed
states breed
our breeding grounds for those type of
people of course i'm worried it's why i
said you know i felt this was not the
right time or decision
to make because of course
al qaeda will probably come back
certainly would like that type of
breeding ground that is what we see
failed states around the world lead to
instability and lead to a security a
threat to us and our interests we we're
very clear about that that's why the
west has to learn that you don't fix
problems you manage problems you know
you you have to you know go into a
country if that's what you're going to
do and you manage it there's no such
thing as an instant fix which i think
it you know is one of the differences
between the west and many parts of the
world
and that's what happened but yes i'm
concerned but we do have capabilities to
protect ourselves even after leaving
afghanistan okay defense actually we're
now out of time i've got another couple
of questions for you if i may lord dana
the former chief of the general staff
says reversing the cut in foreign aid
would help last year to afghanistan it
was 167 and a half million this year
just looked it up this morning 37.5
million a cut of 78 in foreign aid to
afghanistan that would certainly help
with any humanitarian crisis is that
something that the british government
should reconsider
well i think the british government has
been clear that the cut has been a
temporary cut but also you know let's
not forget uh foreign aid is part of it
but remember defense delivers huge
amounts of what we call soft power we
recently had a team in sudan building
a dam for example my soldiers in my
department are constantly around the
world doing humanitarian support not not
pure military support so you know there
are there are a lot of ways to deliver
that uh support but you know one of the
challenges now will be in afghanistan
delivering aid you know are we going to
have to check to the taliban in future
uh especially and that's something that
taliban seem to have uh discarded which
is they were clearly desperate for
international recognition when they made
those choices uh to to to allegedly do
this deal um but you know you don't get
international recognition if you are
committing those atrocities and the like
that we've seen uh being reported so
the new challenge is how do we deliver
aid okay two very quick questions about
stories at home um goku's on the streets
of whitehall you know that they are
starving themselves to death they say
because they want to have a meeting with
you about their pensions
what should we do about it
well first of all that group of people
i'm very happy to meet any gurkha my
father fought alongside the gurkhas and
malaya in the 1950s so uh you know uh it
is a pretty uh remarkable group of
people the the group of people currently
protesting are groups affected uh by the
change by the labour government in 1997
2003
this was about people who were under a
1947 pension it's a very small group of
pensioners they they had different
advantages in their pension scheme
in that old scheme that scheme said that
you got it after 15 years when a british
soldier got off to 22
but there is a difference and and they
feel that that difference needs to be
made up it's been a long-running uh
position of that group that's not the
same as the gurkhas of today or the
gurkhas after 2003 they get exactly the
same pensions as british serving
personnel but of course no government of
any cover labor or conservative or
coalition has ever retrospectively
changed pensions that okay that's not
been the case defense secretary i know
that well you said that you you'd be
willing to meet them i'm sure that that
will probably help that situation so
thank you for the clarification on that
before i let you go the situation in
plymouth this morning
look uh it's a tragedy uh what's
happened there um the police are having
another significant meeting this morning
uh we can rule out terrorism uh from
that event
and i think it it all it does it goes to
underline the importance of issues such
as gun control but also uh you know
what's happening in people's homes up
and down the country it's really four
million our local police forces so they
could be better armed to deal with it
but overall my thoughts are with the
tragic uh loss of life and the people
who you know families who've lost loved
ones today
the police have resolved the situation
is my understanding and we can rule out
terrorism